outrage on social media tonight over
video of a man
seen kicking a cat now it was caught on
a ring camera
what makes it even more upsetting to
those who saw the video the man
was in his work uniform people are
asking for clients now to boycott the
business eight news now reporter sally
jaramillo
has been digging into what exactly
unfolded she's live in the newsroom
tell us what she has learned sally i'm
going to walk you through the video but
i do want to warn you it is disturbing
but the owner says the cat is doing fine
brian this happened in the centennial
hills area last month
and over the last 24 hours has gone
viral
the man is wearing a williams pest
control shirt and hat
in the video you see the cat walking
with the worker then
he stops and looks around when he
doesn't see anyone
he turns and kicks the cat violently
then simply walks off
i did contact the cat's owner he did not
want to go on camera but he tells me he
did get a hold of the company
and had not been cooperative he just
wants to make sure
this doesn't happen again i stopped at
williams pest control on charleston and
jones
it was empty i also made several calls
to them
in a statement from kaylynn williams who
owns the company
she says quote thank you for your
concern and help this has been
devastating for us
and we have no tolerance for animal
cruelty unquote
williams added the person in the video
is not employed by them
and say they have done everything they
can to resolve what happened
they also say they simply want to
provide a good business service for
their customers
and are deeply saddened by his actions
again the cat owner tells me she is ok
and is keeping her indoors so something
like this
never happens again